it's March which means basketball fans  are knee-deep in March Madness seems  like the perfect opportunity for a big  rocket League announcement right I'm  Tony and this game spot news update is a  slam dunk rocket League developer  psionics teased a new basketball mode on  Twitter showing a large hoop instead of  a goal the image also shows a  three-point line so chances are you'll  be able to score more points if you  shoot from further back you better start  practicing those aerials rocket League  has a total of twelve million players  between the ps4 xbox one and pc versions  of the game so we'll see if psionics can  convert all those soccer fans into  basketball players they already did it  with hockey the developer hasn't given a  release date for the new mode but we'll  tell you all about it when we hear more  and for all the rocket League news you  need you already in the right place